how to round numbers you need to just
keep two things in mind write them both
okay the first thing you want to keep in
mind is well how accurate would you like
to be how accurate would you like to be
you might have noticed as we were going
through now a list of five numbers right
we took a number like 631 and we rounded
to the nearest hundred you see that 600
that's the closest thing and this now we
also rounded to the nearest hundred but
these numbers we were a little accurate
we didn't round to the nearest hundred
remanded to the nearest yeah gonna shoot
ten very good kiss boys at 10:52 ten
hundred is also attempt so the first
thing you want to think about is how
accurate would you like to be sometimes
the question will ask you please be this
accurate other times it's up to you to
kind of choose there's the first the
second thing and this is the actual
rounded part is what's the closest
number what's the closest number
once you decided how accurate you would
like to be you just think about well
okay
which one of those is really closer so
let's think about this forty-three that
we do right we already know heads up so
how do we know it went to 40 let me show
you underneath here just write down that
number again 43 there are two tens that
are closest to 43 one's a bit smaller
and one's a bit bigger what are those
two numbers that are close to it very
good so 40 is right here down below and
50 is about two ones bigger and ones
smaller so what work out is well which
was further away what do I have to add
to 43 to get to 50 what's the difference
you're going to give it seven but I have
a look at the other number what do I
have to subtract from 43 to get 40 yep
okay very good
I subtract three so you can clearly see
which one of these is closer right 40 is
why we picked this one because it's a
smaller gap it's close up to 43 now
while we're talking about 40 or 50 I
think we can do all the numbers between
40 and 50 so would you be me right now
we're gonna get all the numbers 41 42 43
44 write them along in a line believe it
a space between them I'm gonna write
them all down and we're gonna do this
comparison it's going
I'm going to do it alright so you can
see my whole list it gets a bit more
crowd at the end this is sorry about
that
baby no miss looks the same I haven't
for 40 or 50 on there and the reason why
is because what I think about what's the
closest number found round into turns 40
and 50 what they are tens right they
don't need to go anywhere they can just
stay where they are so I don't need to
do any changes it's kind of nice so now
that I've got my whole Wistia let's
think about how far they have to go and
how far that to go down to get to these
closest known to this okay now we've
already done wonderful right number 43
so we can fill that in already plus 7 to
go up and take away 3 so you go down so
we already know that one we can fill in
the rest on oh you know quite quickly
because there's a pattern here there's a
pattern for instance if we are if we go
forwards we can see 44 and 50 what I'll
have to add to 44 to get 50 yeah it
seems right go to the next number ever
gonna have to add to 45 to get to 50 now
yeah fine very good I'm gonna pour words
did you see a pattern already forming
there's a really easy faculties in there
what's the next one going to be unity
able to think about do you can get 4
plus 4 very good it's gonna be plus
formal here are and then plus 3 you can
see it's going down one each time let's
fill that all out
and once you go all the way that way
well we might as well finish though the
rest of this going to the left
if you're really quick you can do the
bottom ones as well and do all the
subtractions yeah question 45 which how
do you know ah that's a great question I
will get to 45 minutes the most
interesting went out a lot we will get
to it as a class in a minute
okay so there are some really easy
pursuit and then there are some which
raise a question right so first let's do
the easy ones some of these numbers
they're going to go to the quizzes 10 by
going down recall that rounding down we
already know that's 43 down because 3 is
smaller than 7 this one is going to
round down as well right
there's one more that obviously bounds
now which one is it
which number rounds down that I haven't
done it yeah very good
yeah this one here for this more than 6
on the question at the bottom okay I'll
skip over this guy for a second these
are as you can see it switches over
doesn't it right rounding down it's not
as good anymore
I want to bound oh so all of these four
over here are 46 47 49 rounding up is
what make sense for all of those because
that's close up and then we get to the
cutest case of mr. pointy fire okay so
who can tell me I'm in knows the answer
idiot
which way 45 goes to go up or down you
can tell me shut up it goes up goes up
now everyone shout it out up but that's
kind of weak though like I get confused
when you told me that because plus five
take away five it looks like it's bang
in the middle to me okay now there's a
lot of different answer this question
I'm going to post you so feel free to
shop a few different ones better who
reckons they have my default why why did
you want say plus five I go oh yeah do
it give a suggestion
that's right someone else want to have a
habit cracker
it was like to wait around it's a juicy
one so we notice the fives are the same
it's like well I'm the same distance but
we usually like to add violence
subtracting this is true we learn adding
before you learn strike is much easier
so this is just it it's great because
anyone I want to give another one
suggestion for why okay we'll talk about
which way you would go in a second I'll
talk about that after once we establish
why we do go up enjoy any other
suggestions I want to be more first
let's all put the team on the bus fire
because true 45 we round up to 50 the
main reason why is because you know what
if you're doing a miss see this list of
numbers that were adding if you want to
round down you can the difference is the
same right so how you come out at the
end you'll still be in the same ballpark
there problems
okay however this is just for just for
us just because we're adding Lister
numbers if what you're doing maybe is
rounding but not cutting numbers if you
are rounding something like then you
want to make sure that you and the
person you're paying or vice versa you
want person working it we're collecting
money then you're collecting the same
amount of money that's kind of a big
deal you know what to get there and say
look I had the exact right amount of
money and a min aside you know what I'm
gonna round the other way I'm very
inconvenient one of them so in areas
like that we really want consistency
right we really want to make sure we
have the same answer just like so many
of you shoved up yes round up so that is
why you put in fortunes
for consistency so that we're all
talking the same language we make 45 35
or 25 or 105 we make them all bound up
so that we make sure we all arrive at
the same enzyme just awakens